ان ينوه الى هذا الخبر العاجل حيث افاد
وزير العدل الامريكي بتعيين المستشار خاص
للتحقيق بمساله وجودي وثائق سريه في منزل
الرئيس جوبيدا انه الينا حول هذا الموضوع
من امام وزاره العدل في واشنطن مراسله
الجزيره ناصر الحسيني ذا الناصر ضعنا في
سياق هذا القرار الذي دخله وزير العدل
الامريكي بتعيين المستشار خاص للتحقيق
بمساله وجود وثائق في منزل الرئيس
نعم بالفعل هذه التطورات مهمه جدا على
مستوى السياسه الداخليه في الولايات
المتحده قبل قليل فقط وهو ما زال يتحدث
الان وزير العدل كارلاند انا انه يعينه
مستشار خاصه وهو يعني في الحقيقه محقيقه
خاصه له كافه صلاحيات وسيكون يعمل بشكل
مستقل للبحث في تلك الوثائق التي عثر
عليها مرتين قبل ايام ثم امس ايضا في مراه
شخصيه للرئيس في اقامه شخصيه هناك هذه
وثائق حكوميه تنتهي مع نهايه اي اداره
لكنها سريه بعضها يتحدث عن ايران بعضها
يتحدث عن اوكرانيا بعضها يتحدث عن
العلاقات الامريكيه السريه مع دول في
اوروبا الى اخره
بهذا القرار وزير العدل الذي يعين محقق
خاصه
الان الرئيس بايدن والبيت الابيض ومساعدوه
اتوا دائما الى الامام ولم ي- وقالوا
اكدوا انهم لا يخفون شيئا وعمليات اكتشاف
هذه الوثائق يقوموا بها اصلا مساعد
وبالتالي البيت الابيض سيجد نفسه الان في
موقف الدفاع لان هناك سببا يجعل البيت
الابيض قلقا في كاس العمايل المقبلين وهو
ان هناك اصوات بدات في الكونغرس تطالب
بتحقيقات على مستوى الكونغرس ليس فقط على
مستوى وزاره العدل كثيرون في اعضاء
الكونغرس يعتقدون ان المحقق الخاص مع كامل
قوته واستقلالته سيكون كافيه للاجابه على
اهم الاسئله
كيف تم التصرف معها لماذا لم يتم حفظها مع
نهايه فتره الرئاسيه للرئيس اوباما انا
ذاك وكان مساعد له من الذي تصرف كيف تصرف
وبالتالي اليات قانونيه معروفه في
الولايات المتحده مع نهايه كل اداره يتم
وضع تلك الوثائق في همم العرشيف الوطنيه
او القومي هذا لم يحدث في هذه الحاله
البيت الابيض قاعد بانه يساعد وزاره العدل
الان تفتح تحقيقا واعضاء الكونجرس
الجمهوريون يريدون تحقيقا على مستوى
الكونجرس يتم تاسيسه بطريقه حال لكن اعضاء
الكونجرس ليسوا كلهم على نفس الموقف
وكثيرون يعتقدون ان مبادره وزاره العدل
العدل اليوم كافيه لنصل الى
الاجابه على هذه العمليه
يعني هذه الخطوات من هذا النوع الى ماذا
يمكن ان تكون كفيله بامتصاص هذا الغضب
لا يبدو انها ستمتص غضب الجمهوريه مكافي
وكما سمعناهم منذ امس يطالب بلجنه تحقيق
مستقله على غرار ما قام به ما قام به
الديمقراطيون وهم يحققون مع الرئيس ترامب
يريدون تحقيقا من هذا النوع لكن حتى الان
الكونغرس بنفسه منقسم ستكون هناك غضب
سيكون هناك نوع من محاوله انتقام سياسي من
الديمقراطيين لكن ليس هناك خارطه طريق
واضحه لا نعرف بالفعل ان كان الكونجرس
سيخوض زمام البوبادره وسيعل وينشئ لجنته
الخاصه
في انتقاد اداره الرئيس والحقيقه ان الامر
يتعلق بوفقائق جمهوريون يرون ان بيدنس هذه
العمليه يقولون ان الرئيس ايضا هذه
الاداره الديمقراطيه ينقضت على الرئيس
ترامب في مساله الوثائق جوه اختراق
وهجوم الانبياء على منزل مع الارض وفي
ولايه فلوريدا للسيارات ترامب الرئيس
الاسبق وهذا لا يظهر حاليا وبالتالي
يقولون ان هناك تعامل بالكيل بالمكيالين
تخص قول الامريكيه ولكن في الوقت نفسه
ايضا الرئيس بيضا عندما يقارن مع الرئيس
ترامب هناك فارق من شاسع ايضا ياتي قدما
يقدم ويساعد وزاره العدل رئيس ترامب يغفر
وثائق ولا يريد اعادتها الى حيث يجب ان
تكون الخلاف سياسي ما هو الا البدايه
حاليا الان وانا نعرف اي خريطه الطريق في
الحقيقه
المشكله المشكله
انه تعيين مستشار خاص للتحقيق بمساله وجود
وثائق سريه في منزل الرئيس
كذلك وزير العدل الامريكي ناصر يتحدث عن
ان مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي يجري تقييما
لتحديد مدى انتهاك القانون بشان الوثائق
السريه ويقول بانه سيضمنوا ان المستشار
الخاص بالوثائق السريه يتلقى جميع الموارد
التي يحتاجها للقيام بعمله لك ناصر يعني
دخول مكتب بي اي او مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه على خط تقييم مدى انتهاك
القانون بشان هذه الوثائق السريه الى اي
مدى يملا بخطوره ما يوكا يكون متابعات
لهذه القضيه
اتبعات ستكون عندما مستقبلا في وقت ما يجد
المحقق الخاص بان هناك بالفعل جيرمن
سياسيا تم اقترافه حتى الان هي اتهامات
همم ولا نقول اشاعه لكنها اتهامات مبنيه
على بعض المعطيات لكن الاهم في كل هذا ان
البيت الابيض والاداره الامريكيه تحت رئيس
ايضا تتعاون وتاتي قدما تقدم الملفات تعطي
المعلومات وتقدم ايضا حتى الشهود من
العالم الان انا بدات تحقيق منذ يومين او
ثلاثه مع مقربين من رئيس الحالي الذين عمل
معه في فتره نهائيات رئيس اوباما حيث تلك
الوثائق حوالي 10 وثائق تتعلق ببعض الدول
العربيه باوكرانيا بالعلاقات السريه
الامريكيه حتى الان لم يثبت بعد ان هناك
جورما وخطا في التعامل مع تلك المعلومات
لم يثبت بعد ان تلك المعلومات السريه خرجت
الى العمل
ان كان هناك ذنب او الخطا ان كان هناك خطا
لم اثبت بعد قانونيا وذلك بصدر الى حد
كبير هذا المساعده والدور الدور المساعده
الذي يقوم به البيت الابيض في الامتثال
لكل اوامر المحققين وبالتالي بدايه مرحله
جديده تضع الرئيس بعضنا ولا شك في موقف
الدفاع اشكرك ناصر الحسيني
من امام وزاره العدل الامريكيه في واشنطن